was richard feynman a liar he invented
quantum electrodynamics created feynman
diagrams predicted nanotechnology and
quantum computing he solved the riddle
of the challenger explosion and won the
nobel prize but in his memoir surely
you're joking mr feynman he relates a
story i think i got three patents i
don't know what they are anymore three
patents have my name on it there's no
record of a single patent let alone
three was the old nobel laureate just
mistaken even great minds as sound as
his warned us the first principle is you
should not fool yourself and you are the
easiest person to fool great geniuses
can make great mistakes so you be the
judge did feynman forget
did he fool himself
or was richard feynman a liar